okay so today's topic will be on
fermentation you know we're gonna start
by making sense out of this diagram
right here so as we go through this
presentation we're gonna talk about a
variety of cellular reactions and
chemical reactions and one thing I'd
want to just remind you the whole
purpose of these chemical reactions is
gonna be to make a molecule called
adenosine triphosphate ATP this is the
energy molecule needed by our cells so
how cells make ATP and their energy well
it depends on a few certain factors and
that's what we're gonna talk about right
now aerobic versus anaerobic respiration
so when we go through fermentation you
know before we actually discuss
fermentation we need to talk about what
glycolysis is glycolysis is a chemical
reaction where a molecule of glucose
will be broken down into a couple
molecules called pyruvate that is a very
short symbolic diagram of what happens
during glycolysis well what about those
pyruvates that are left over well
there's two pathways that will happen
next one pathway is anaerobic pathway
and one pathway is an anaerobic pathway
so let's follow the aerobic pathway
first if oxygen is present then those
pyruvates generally will head to the
mitochondria and within the mitochondria
is where the Krebs cycle occurs and then
following the krebs cycle the electron
transport chain and these steps
glycolysis the Krebs cycle the electron
transport chain generally make a lot of
ATP one molecule of glucose can make
anywhere from 36 to 38 molecules of ATP
this is viewed as the aerobic pathway
the pathway that the cell typically
follows with the presence of oxygen
however there's an anaerobic pathway
sometimes cells are devoid or without
oxygen and in that case the pyruvates
that are left over when glycolysis is
finished
be used and broken down into either
lactic acid or ethyl alcohol depending
on the type of fermentation that occurs
and once these two products lactic acid
or ethyl alcohol have been created that
will allow the lye calluses to restart
over and over and over and the cell gets
caught up in this loop of performing
glycolysis and fermentation that's what
we're going to talk about specifically
today
so let's start by breaking down
glycolysis this is the chemical process
that starts in the cytoplasm and what
happens is a molecule of glucose gets
broken down by molecules of ATP nad
and a variety of enzymes now for
simplicity I've drawn glucose as the six
blue C's arranged in hexagons formation
now in reality there's also 12
hydrogen's and six oxygens but for
simplicity I've only drawn the six
carbons of glucose and so what's gonna
happen is two molecules of ATP are gonna
begin to break down that glucose with
the help of various enzymes so here's a
molecule of ATP and my scissors
represent one of the enzymes and when
the ATP molecule gets broken the glucose
is broken down into this intermediate
molecule right here now this
intermediate molecule doesn't last very
long because a second molecule of ATP
and a different enzyme once the ATP is
broken down energy is released and that
intermediate gets broken down into a
couple molecules which I'm just gonna
call P gal fossil glyceraldehydes notice
how each of them are three carbon
molecules well originally this was a
molecule of glucose which had six
carbons so next enzymes which are in the
cytoplasm will add another phosphate
onto each of the P gals so here's an
enzyme the scissors adding a phosphate
to the P gal on the left and and the
phosphate being added to the P gal on
the right and by doing this this
converts the P gal into another
intermediate molecule so next a couple
molecules abbreviated NADH will be
created now NADH starts out as a
molecule called an ad or nad and nad
stands for nicotinamide adenine
dinucleotide so just for ease and
simplicity I'm gonna just call it mad
and what happens is of course there's
enzymes involved I just didn't show the
enzyme but nad will strip off a hydrogen
and generally we'll carry that hydrogen
over to the mitochondria now this
happens on the right side as well the
other nad will strip off a hydrogen and
generally will usually carry it over to
the mitochondria next so now that we're
near the end of glycolysis let's focus
on those four yellow peas that I've
drawn those represent phosphate groups
now I've also just added four molecules
of ADP and what happens is an ADP
molecule along with an enzyme will break
off one of those phosphates to make a
molecule of ATP now this will happen
three more times a molecule of EDP along
with an enzyme will break off one of
those phosphates to make ATP and ADP
with the help of an enzyme will strip
off a phosphate to make ATP and an ADP
along with the help of enzymes will
strip off a phosphate to make ATP and so
notice what we're left with two
molecules labeled pyruvate now those
that when we began we had a molecule of
glucose now it's left over these
molecules of pyruvate these are gonna be
really important when we move on into
fermentation next notice also four
molecules of ATP were created but we say
a net gain glycolysis makes a net gain
of two ATP's why well even though
glycolysis made four in the end two
ATP's were started were used two ATP's
were used to start the process of
glycolysis so when you subtract the two
that were required to start from the
four that were created we say a net gain
of two ATP molecules was created well
now let's move on into fermentation
well there's actually two kinds of
fermentation and we're gonna start with
lactic acid fermentation this is the
fermentation performed by animals such
as bears and humans and as well also
this fermentation lactic acid
fermentation is performed by microscopic
bacteria and when we think about
bacteria we actually use the lactic acid
fermentation process of bacteria to make
many food products it's for instance
it's what gives sourdough bread its
distinct flavor we also use the back
certain species of bacteria in the
process of fermenting cucumbers in order
to make pickles and in the production of
yogurt it's what gives yogurt its it's
kind of sour taste to it because the
bacteria produce lactic acid which has a
sour taste and so let's go into that
cellular process next okay so lactic
acid fermentation occurs in the
cytoplasm of cells and it occurs when
cells do not receive enough oxygen in
order to perform the Krebs cycle and the
electron transport chain which is what
cells would prefer to do the krebs cycle
and the electron transport chain make a
large amount of ATP but in order to do
this the cell needs and the mitochondria
specifically needs oxygen but there are
times when cells don't have enough
oxygen and so they have to perform
lactic acid fermentation now you might
be thinking about why would a cell not
have oxygen well for instance you know
there's a problem
during exercise or let's say you're
playing a sporting activity sporting
contest your muscles need a lot of ATP
because they're working really hard
well solution is why don't you just make
more ATP after all you can break down
your glucose in your body to make more
ATP that seems like a pretty obvious
solution right well there's a new
problem oxygen is needed to produce the
vast amounts of ATP through the crowd
cycle and the electron transport chain
but because you're involved in exercise
or you're playing a sporting activity
your muscles are working really hard so
they're actually deprived of oxygen your
muscles aren't getting enough oxygen so
you could stop but that would defeat the
purpose of exercise and if you're in the
middle of a sporting contest you're not
going to just stop in the middle of the
court or the field and let the soccer
players go around doing the basketball
players go around here you're not gonna
just stop you're gonna keep continuing I
hope so there's a new solution here is
that fermentation allows the cells to
make ATP without the use of oxygen and
let's explain that
so fermentation occurs after glycolysis
and when we left off
we had the NADH go to the mitochondria
but I'm gonna get rid of the
mitochondria in my animation not because
the mitochondria is disappeared because
but because it's not involved in this
process without oxygen everything stays
in the cytoplasm and what's gonna happen
is those two pyruvate so let's focus on
the pyruvate to the left it's gonna gain
a hydrogen from NADH and enzyme
represented by my scissors we'll bring
together the pyruvate and the NADH and
the pyruvate will strip off a hydrogen
creating nad well now that the pyruvate
has the hydrogen it's not called
pyruvate anymore it's now called lactic
acid and notice how a molecule of nad
was recreated well this happens in the
other pyruvate as well here's another
pair of scissors representing an enzyme
and NADH and the enzyme and the pyruvate
are joined together and the pyruvate
strips off a hydrogen creating lactic
acid two molecules of lactic acid that
begins to build up and that's what
causes that familiar soreness as we
continue to exercise and you know work
our muscles really hard so now that the
lactic acids been created its release as
a waste and as I said a moment ago
begins to build up
and it accumulates in our muscle and
that's what causes that familiar burning
sensation whenever we go up a lot of
stairs or were involved in heavy
exercise that burning in our muscles
well that's from the accumulation of
lactic acid well let's finish off lactic
acid fermentation why is the NAD so
important well it helps to restart
glycolysis here's a new molecule of
glucose and glucose can be broken down
with the help of ATP with enzymes and
with nad and when that happens molecules
of ATP get created but if I were to ask
you how much ATP is actually created
through fermentation I hope you know the
answer is zero
fermentation does not make any ATP it
makes some lactic acid waste but more
importantly it makes nad and NADH realm
of glycolysis
well how much ATP is made through
glycolysis well you can say a total of
four ATP's or you can say a net gain of
two because two ATP's are required to
start glycolysis
you know while we're on the topic I
might as well bring up a few ways to
help recover from an exercise you know
after exercise you might be a little
sore so you know good ways to relieve
maybe some of the soreness would be
through massage whether it's through a
professional masseuse or using a foam
roller to kind of give yourself a
massage also eating bananas which are
high in potassium potassium is really
important in your muscles ability to
stretch and contract so eating bananas
is a key nutrient in muscle recovery
proper hydration not just during your
activity but pre and during and
post-workout properly hydrating yourself
is one of the keys to you know reducing
it and preventing soreness in the first
place and also performing a post stretch
I think most people know to do a pre
stretch before you perform any vigorous
activity but a lot of people don't
always think about a post stretch and
it's one of the better ways to help
relieve muscle soreness
so as we shift focus to the other kind
of fermentation alcoholic fermentation
this is the fermentation generally
performed by yeasts which are a type of
fungus and they're responsible for the
production of alcoholic beverages and
for the production of most bread I
mentioned sourdough earlier well
sourdough is produced by lactic acid
fermentation but most other breads are
produced through yeast and the actions
of alcoholic fermentation so during
alcoholic fermentation this process
occurs in the cytoplasm and because the
mitochondria is not involved I'm gonna
remove it from my animation generally
speaking this occurs in yeasts and even
some plants and so what happens is
here's a pair of scissors representing
an enzyme and the enzymes gonna break
down the pyruvate on the left now
remember the pyruvates were just created
through glycolysis so here's the enzyme
breaking down the pyruvate notice how
some carbon dioxide waste was created
along with a two carbon intermediate
molecule so let's focus on that two
carbon intermediate what happens next is
NADH well with the help of an enzyme
NADH with the help of an enzyme the NADH
will actually lose its hydrogen the
hydrogen will be stripped off by the two
carbon intermediate molecule free up the
nad and notice what's left behind is
ethanol another name for ethanol is
ethyl alcohol it's the alcohol created
during fermentation well the same thing
is gonna happen to the pyruvate on the
right so here's a great time to review
these two steps that are in the notes
step one says it and as I'm will break
down pyruvate well here's an enzyme the
enzyme will break down pyruvate and co2
is released this also leaves behind this
two carbon intermediate molecule well
then we move on to step reviewing step
- here's another enzyme and the enzyme
along with NADH the NADH will have its
hydrogen stripped off by that - carbon
intermediate creating an ad and another
molecule of ethanol so focus on the
ethanol the ethanol is released as a
waste and the carbon dioxide was
released as a waste so why is alcoholic
fermentation important what was created
is the nad the nad will help to restart
glycolysis so here's another molecule of
glucose enzymes plus the nad plus
molecules of ATP will break down that
glucose to make more ATP oh and by the
way if I were to ask you how much ATP is
created through alcoholic fermentation
again the answer is zero no kind no ATP
is made through alcoholic or lactic acid
fermentation the purpose of fermentation
though is to make those na DS and those
na DS will help to restart glycolysis
and how much ATP will be created through
the light alysus well you can say for a
total or a net gain of two you know
earlier I mentioned that bread is
created by yeast as they perform
alcoholic fermentation so what causes
bread dough to rise in the baking
process well I hope you know the answer
is the carbon dioxide as the carbon
dioxide is released by the cells of
yeast the carbon dioxide gas causes the
dough to fluff up and the bread rises
well you might be asking if bread is
created through alcoholic fermentation
well then why isn't bread alcoholic well
that's because of the baking process in
the process of baking bread the heat
from the oven causes the ethanol the
alpha alcohol to be burned away and it
simply evaporates so as we finish up
this video you know here's a real short
practice quiz
for you to try and you know if you're in
my class maybe write your answers on a
sheet of paper and I'm happy to check
your answers before a score or after
school and also leave your comments in
the box below I'd love to hear what you
thought of this video thanks for
watching